the more that i open up and i talk about
them yes it's gonna help me but it's
also gonna help
x number of people and that right there
you know i could save one
five ten a hundred thousand lives and
that right there is way better than ever
winning an olympic gold medal
um so that's you know that's that's why
i try to get up every day and
you know attack every day with purpose
okay michael phelps demar derozan
um thanks so much for being here and
having a conversation that
is incredibly necessary and incredibly
important
uh surrounding mental health and it's
great that you guys have
lended your voices to this so much and
i'm excited to have this discussion
i felt like it was very important though
to start off by making sure everybody
knows that people who are
affected by mental health or affected by
depression are not a monolith
and not everybody is the same so i want
to ask you both
what does depression look like and feel
like
for you for me it honestly can
look different depending on
i guess how dark of a place i'm in
um so it depends on how much i've
i've let things pile up and and for me
it's a pretty negative
i don't want to be around anybody
[Music]
and every little small thing will set me
off
uh and basically almost like i think i
go back into
um a thought of like not being good
enough
and and you know i think for me
throughout my career
i i struggle with a long time for a long
time
looking in the mirror and seeing myself
as a human being and not
as just a swimmer like that's all i
really saw myself as and
and almost like a product um so
until i was able to get past that moment
um
it was it was a struggle yeah demar
saying you know i think um exactly what
mike said
is definitely that same type of feeling
of um solid
solitary confinement for me is you know
being in that dark place and you know it
seems like
everything triggers you and you can't
figure out
a reason why it's triggering you but
you're taking out you know your
frustration
aggression out on you know everything
that's
in your way you know i think for me it's
been times
um where i struggle being in a room full
of people and
feel like i'm in there all alone you
know and uh
that always been something that affected
me when i was when i had my dark days my
dark moments
you know and it comes out of nowhere um
when you least suspected you could be
smiling one second
and before you know it you're in a place
of wondering how you got there why i got
there and you asked so many questions
um you know and it's kind of frustrating
you know so that's
that's that's what it looked like from
from for me
one thing that you both touch answers
about what depression looks like for you
is it really is something that only you
can see
right depression isn't like physical
things where everybody else can see
maybe something is wrong or maybe this
person needs help
and i think that because you guys both
have these very public
careers people obviously do not know
that something is wrong
you know you guys have been at the
height of athletics smiling with medals
or trophies smiling after big wins
but i guess my question is through your
career despite
all of that how often were you actually
happy i think i think for me my
my pure hacking moments always came
when i was out there on a basketball
court you know um
one of my close friends i played with
you know i always used to talk to him
about everything he always
we always had the sand right after games
you know
for me it was always like now it's back
to reality because
while i was out there playing you know
that's why i was the most free
most at peace um most myself and had the
utmost confidence in myself
but as soon as you walk walk off from
there it's like
now you back to that isolation in in in
your brain and your thoughts and
everything kind of takes over from there
and you know and it seems like the two
two and a half hours that i was out on
basketball court didn't even exist
because now i'm dealing with
this whole feeling of you know being in
a depressed mindset and not
understanding why when it just it wasn't
a thought when i was just out there
playing so for me
it always came when when when i was able
to play basketball
michael i think in the weight of gold a
common theme
is so many athletes defining themselves
by their sport and you alluded to that
off top as well
how do you get out of that
mindset i'll talk about may i i'll talk
about me so
when when i really i guess learned more
about myself and was able to
grow and understand why i was going up
and down and up and down
i i had to be willing and
ready to learn um and and become
vulnerable and and
for me uh it was probably the most scary
thing i've ever done in my life
um but i i
knew that i wanted change and and you
know after spending four or five days in
my room and not wanting to be alive not
talking to anybody
anybody not eating anything nothing at
all um
you know after that i felt like there
had to be something else
and a way that i could get help
um but also like i like to add
to mars point like it's the same thing
for me
um after my first retirement when i
stepped away from the pool all i wanted
to do was stiff arm it and never see it
never smell chlorine never see a lane
line again
and after my second retirement
it's almost therapy for me it's the one
time where i can get peace and quiet and
and i can let my mind just do whatever
it needs to do
uh because i i can i mean
we've we've done our sports for so long
we'd almost do it on autopilot
um so you know like to an extent so i
can get in and float for
you know a thousand fifteen hundred you
know two models
and not even think about anything but
get out of the water and
feel like a completely different person
um so it's it's it's wild how
i like it it all like life comes back
full circle
yeah absolutely i think
one thing in the documentary that
stuck out a lot was everybody feeling
like
this system can do more to help
it's equally important because
as athletes you know you kind of get to
a point to where you just
become athletes and
forget that we are human beings to where
that part
is everything you know you lose control
and lose focus on your mental
everything else could fall apart and
sometimes
being an athlete you can get lost in
preparation training you know
years go by where you never address the
mental issue
of what you're going to be going through
what you're going to be dealing with and
how to
cope with it you know until you oh old
enough to
realize like yo i i something's wrong
with me let me figure this thing out and
how
i could get out of this feeling or why
why all of a sudden all these dark
feelings coming
out of nowhere you know so much that
that comes
on the mission of becoming a great
athlete that
get overlooked because it's all about
you being a great athlete
not knowing like your mental health and
everything that you go through person
personally everything is is more
important than just being an athlete
and i'll say like i i feel that
through the olympic space uh i mean i've
been in
the last five olympics and and through
my 20 years
spending working with the usoc i've
never
felt that they were as interested in our
mental health
as they were our physical health and to
me that makes zero sense
because if they want to make us the
strongest person people that we can
possibly be
then they should be looking at that from
both sides not just
one or the other like um i i would just
feel that
if we're uh strengthening both sides of
that then that just makes
us naturally almost even more unbeatable
so like it's just something that nobody
really wants to address and
to see and to admit and and this is
something that we have to address
because there
are so many people out there that that
haven't had the courage to stand up and
talk about it um
you know it took me through five
olympics to realize that i wasn't alone
um in 2016 when i was the flag bear and
when i was the captain you know standing
there and watching these athletes or
listening to what they were saying
i i realized that that i was not alone
and i
it honestly scared the crap out of me
because i i didn't know how i made it
through my career dealing with what i
did and and
some of these kids were just starting
their career and
and as you know we see suicide rate
the suicide rate continue to climb and
that's something that that has to change
um and and we need to work together and
we need to start by communicating
that's something that that for me i'll
say changed my life
um i always make the joke i learned to
communicate at the age of 30.
so at least i learned something
i'll fill you on that one tomorrow
one thing that that when you find
yourself
going into a tailspin that can help you
redirect whether it's going outside and
looking at sun playing video games
playing golf watching tv whatever it
might be
i think for me like i just i just got to
go outside like and like hear
the peaceful like like last few years
i've been big on like nature i got to be
around nature to find calm
you know what i mean like just complete
peace quiet nature
and that kind of always helped me
regroup and kind of settle down
in a faster way than everything else
yeah it helps you ground yeah
it makes total sense it's like i feel
i i feel similar like we've i've always
lived in baltimore
i've been a city boy my whole life so um
coming to arizona where i actually get
to see
wildlife and and uh a desert and
sunshine and a blue sky every day
um i i started seeing different critters
and
and realizing that it's it really is
magical
like what we get to see and be every
single day so yeah
i can agree that there's so much nothing
like going on
full moon and just sinking your feet
into yeah
michael i wanted to touch on something
that you said when you mentioned that
this affects so many people so many
athletes and olympians you know
in the weight of gold documentary you
said it's safe to say
that a good 80 of athletes go through
some sort of post-olympic depression
that is a very large percentage so how
often do you guys discuss those feelings
with one another
and does it help i would say before 2016
never
um because it was never really talked
about because
if we do open up and talk about
something like that then that
means we're showing a sign of weakness
and we're giving an advantage to our
competitors so
for me i i would never let anybody
get inside like under my skin period
like if you're just not it's not
happening
um but like that was something that that
we couldn't show
um and and for me like i
it's bad to say this i feel like i could
have gotten a gold medal for
compartmentalizing
um because i mean i would go years with
just letting things pile up before they
exploded and
and i would just recreate the same thing
go on that cycle for
20 years um so i think now
being able to have the help from so many
athletes celebrities um
human beings who have just had the
courage to stand up
and and um you know find vulnerability
and and
you know talk about things that they
struggle with i really think we've been
able to see a lot of change and open up
a lot of conversation
i think we're scratching the surface and
i think there's a ton
a ton more that we can do and we'll
learn through this process
demar what have you learned from
vulnerability
um the
oh that's something that
i never thought would would exist like
like michael says
as a competitor you never want to give
nobody no type of edge
ever no signs of weakness no type no
signs of
signs of a way of being attacked
so for me when i when i came out and
expressed my story
you see and felt like
the positive like it felt like i went to
another world of
uplifting you know a lot of people
always come to me and say how much i
helped them but the response that i got
back
gave me a feeling that i never would
have thought would have been there
like it kind of gave me a sort of
empowering
of letting you know it's okay to be
vulnerable
you know and it kind of frustrates you
in a moment because it's like damn
it would have been like this if i would
have said someone
share my story you know so for me it was
it's it's being vulnerable and as a man
it took me to be 27 years old
when i turned 27 when i shared my my
story to accept
being okay with being vulnerable you
know and in it showed me
how to be a man you know and it and it
took
for me to be able to look at my kids and
them give give me the empathy and
the power to feel like i know i'm a
great dad like
nothing else matters if somebody else
judged me if i come out
and express my story you know so that
it gave me a a sense of of confidence
and empowerment that i never thought
would be there with coming out showing
vulnerability
your shoulders feel good right like it's
just yeah
yeah it's just like yeah you just like
like
what the yeah why is that so different
yeah like you know so and it also makes
you think like
damn there's so many people who go
through so much and it lasts longer they
don't find a way
or comfort don't want to be vulnerable
or let loose you know so many people
suppress
you know their pain and thoughts with so
much other stuff like at least we had
sports uh
sports take away basketball i have no
clue where i'd be
you know what i mean and it made me look
at people in a whole different way
and why i can never judge people i
shouldn't talk to whether if you
if you're a kid i didn't have people
twice my age come to me and thank me for
for thing for things that they've been
going through that they just now
realizing how to get through so that's
what it's about for me
you know it's bigger than just sports
it's about it's about
being human yeah exactly absolutely
yeah you know michael i i think so many
people are going to be so
incredibly touched by the weight of gold
film
i i when you watch it it's so clear that
this is something that is so
important and needs to be discussed more
so i'm sure
i thank you and on behalf of everybody's
probably going to watch the film
um it was it's so great and i encourage
everybody to
to view it you know you vote
even me even me like even like mike's
story
was was so uplifting and
empowering for me because it's like you
know
i i think the outside people don't
realize how much we lean
towards you know our peers in our
position when you could you could
you don't necessarily get a chance to
see our and hear our true story other
than be an athlete so
when you get an insight that's the most
biggest motivation for me like mike
story there's so many other guys story
that i swear i pay attention to that
no one would have a clue that i know
their story that helps me
get up the next day and do whatever it
is i need to do
you know what i mean so i think that's
what it's about being
being human you know um paying attention
listening to people's stories because
everybody got a story
that we could be motivated and find that
confidence to get through whatever it is
we're going through
100 agree like i think that's the
biggest thing it just shows that
no matter who you are no matter what
walk of life you you are
in your being and you're gonna go
through ups and downs and you're
some of them might be similar might be
different but you know what it's my
story it's your story it's our story and
that's what makes us us
and it's so it's it's extremely
frustrating to see
how many people judge or how many people
you know will say
certain things about you know coming out
and talking about this stuff because
it's like come on like
we're we're supposed to help each other
become better human beings and stronger
and try to push the envelope
to how much farther and how many better
things we can do
so why not work together right i feel
like that's something that's
it's been so fun for me to hear um
everybody's story has been able to come
out
and and found the courage um to share
i mean it ain't easy uh um
and and uh you know i know it's it's uh
you know i've opened up multiple times
like really
in depth and been like extremely raw and
and
for me like i i to your point tomorrow
like i i've almost felt
freer after it you know like i've been
afraid of saying or sharing some of
these dark things that go into my head
or you know
these experiences that i go through but
the more that i open up and i talk about
them yes it's gonna help me but it's
also gonna help
x number of people and that right there
you know i could save one
five ten a hundred thousand lives and
that right there is way better than ever
winning an olympic gold medal
um so that's you know that's that's why
i try to get up every day and
you know attack every day with purpose
absolutely you know you both have been
you know focused on being the best at
your sport since a very young age
so besides the vulnerability aspect
what do you wish young damar young
michael knew from the very beginning
and i'll start with you tomorrow the
heartache how hard
the heartache will be pushing for
something you love
and losing so many people that you love
in the process
i think for me that was the hardest
thing because everybody don't understand
the dedication you put into something
you love and that you want so much
and sometimes you do it out of your own
pain
internally you know it's like i worked
so hard to escape this feeling
but everybody wanted to enjoy
the good stuff that came with me working
so hard when
i really was working hard to suppress my
pain
my my my my dark
days my dark nights where i felt so
alone you know so
i wish i would have understood that and
not let it
affect me so bad once when other people
probably didn't get it in the moment
and i always was scared to communicate
and tell people like
you know why you work so hard and you
really don't like going out or why you
don't like doing this it's like yo i
work hard because
one this is the only time i get to
escape
and you don't see that i'm really
screaming for help at times when i'm i i
become
tunnel vision and working so hard to
tell me pull me to the side and you know
sometimes you just want
that hug you sometimes you know
like i know i'm i'm the type of friend
to wear if i'm in the car with the
with my friend they driving i don't care
where you drive i'm riding with you just
so you could
so you don't feel alone like i was
always in search of that
feeling and for me not being the person
who communicate
and always wanted that feeling you know
i wish i would have understood how to
communicate that at a young age to say
yo
i need this to help me get through this
because
i'm gonna have up and down days but i
need you to be my crush because i'm
my whole family crush crutch my whole
friend's crutch like everybody lean on
me but i don't have nobody lean over
you know so i tell myself that
you know so i wouldn't wait til i was 27
and suffer from so much depression and
dark days and
frustrating days and nights so that's
one thing i tell myself
yeah michael what would you tell
yourself from the beginning
uh we have a lot of similarities um yeah
i
i know the feeling of tunnel vision and
and pushing yourself beyond belief
um i can't tell you how many days i
spent staring at that black line on the
bottom of the pool screaming in the
water
nobody can hear me so i would use that
as
frustration and motivation and and that
would help me go to that next level
so i think in a nutshell i would say i
would change to zero
because um i don't think i would be able
to look at myself in the mirror today
and feel how i do
i think the journey that i had and the
things that i went through allowed me
to love who i am um and that's the first
time i've ever had that so
um was it scary was it rocky
um did i not think i would make it
through at some point
yes but it also made me who i am today
and hopefully my journey i
can guide my boys into
potentially not making some of the
mistakes that i did and
equipping them with some more tools at
the start of the weight of gold
documentary
someone asks you about your goals and we
see a young you
say that it's to win a gold medal which
you have absolutely done
but obviously now life is different
so what are your goals now and what do
you strive for
now well i mean i'm still connected to
the swimming
world i i do have a swimming brand so
for me to learn to swim water safety is
something that's very important
that's the only reason why i ever got
into the water and drowning for children
under the age of 14 is the second
highest cause of death
so as a dad that scares the living hell
out of me even though i am
who i am so
that you know with my foundation that is
one thing that we are trying to teach as
many kids as we possibly can and adults
just to be water safe
um continue the the destigmation of
mental health that's something that you
know i
knew was going to be very challenging
when when i first opened up
and and decided that i was going to try
to break down this wall as fast as i
could
and and i think now living it for four
years and experiencing and hearing some
of the stories that i've heard
it is going to be probably even harder
but that makes me even happier
uh that means i work even harder and and
uh
that's just how i work so it's it kind
of makes it more enjoyable for me i'm a
process
driven person um so uh plus i have three
kids um
trying to maintain a household and keep
that in order
um i have a busy busy uh schedule it's
kind of crazy with quarantine i'm
actually jealous of damar and some of
the other athletes who are playing right
now
and i'm being able to have some
competition that that sounds
uh like uh it's probably the first thing
that i want to do
um i played golf with some friends this
morning and and
some pga pro guys and um they were
talking about the the camaraderie
between the
the other athletes on tour and and
i thought about you instantly i was like
dude that's got to be insane
in disney in a bubble like that it's got
to be wild but it's got to be kind of
fun too you're like a kid in the candy
store so
um
yeah absolutely well i i know i have
said it i'll say it again
weight of gold tackles so many different
things in terms of expectations from
others from yourself mental health
suicidal thoughts
taking that stigma away also just
understanding that your worth you know
is tied to more than just what you do so
i appreciate both of you for always
speaking on that i appreciate you
michael for making the film you demar
for always being so open and
it's an important thing to watch so i
just thank you guys
so much for your time thank you no no
worries
let me just say one more thing um yeah
absolutely i think
i think it was wild with the documentary
because
so many are so many of our stories were
different
but they were almost like pretty
identical
um so you know i think it it really just
shows you
that there are so many or potentially so
many people out there who are struggling
from similar things
just like tamar and i are um so you know
again i i'd like to just say to
everybody out there who's watching this
who is
experiencing something like this you're
not alone um and and trust me
i never thought i'd be able to do what i
did with going through what i did
but you know i i believed that anything
was possible
and i wanted my dream bad enough so
you know don't let anything hold you
back don't let anybody doubt you out
just because we're going through
something difficult
doesn't make us less of a human being
[Music]
you